now a related idea to just what a
bureaucracy is in our federal government
another question is how do they get
influenced
now one idea that you might see in many
american government courses is the idea
of an iron triangle
so an iron triangle describes how
various parties might influence each
other and what they might do for each
other so let's say that there is a group
that is very interested in
building more roads maybe there's a
group that represents all the the road
contractors in the united states and
they would love more highways to be
built because there would be more
business for them and so then that
interest group who wants more highways
to be built they might say hey congress
people we want more highways built
and the way that they try to get favor
with congress is through electoral
support now what kind of electoral
support could they give
well they could donate money to the
congressman directly
they could donate money to political
parties they could try to activate the
electorate to vote for a congress person
who favors their agenda more than
someone else
an exchange congress people could do a
few things they could provide more
funding to the bureaucracy that is going
to build roads and we just talked about
that bureaucracy in the executive branch
and those that bureaucracy not only
might they build more roads but if they
like those interest groups they might
lower the regulations on them they might
give them more contracts as they build
those roads another thing that congress
could do for the interest group is pass
friendly legislation so maybe pass a law
that makes it easier to build roads in a
certain part of the country or in a
certain way
but the reason why it's called an iron
triangle it's it's not just about what
do interest groups want it's also what
does congress want what does the
bureaucracy want and what do they get
from the other two parties so we already
talked about how congress can get
electoral support from interest groups
but what can it get from a bureaucracy
congress passes laws in a budget but a
bureaucracy for the most part decides
how to execute on that and so if there
are if they are aligned with congress
they might execute on those laws with a
little bit more energy if the
bureaucracy for one reason or another is
not as gung-ho about those laws they
might drag their feet a little bit
and from the bureaucracy point of view
well we already talked how they could
get funding and political support from
congress you see that on that part of
the triangle there
what do they get from the interest
groups well we already talked about the
congressional support which they can do
by supporting congress people who might
support favorable policies for the
bureaucracy the interest groups might be
able to directly lobby congress which
means hey we're going to meet with
congress we might even draft some things
some things for the policy agenda
now a related idea to an iron triangle
in interest groups that you might also
hear in an american government course is
the notion of issue
networks
one way to think about issue networks is
they are essentially more informal than
interest groups interest groups can be
part of an issue network but an issue
network can be let's say you and i start
to get really activated about something
we get on tv and then we start mailing
our congress people and we start
blogging about it and we start getting a
following and then that starts to
influence an interest group where
interest group joins with us and then we
start to send messages to congress we
start to provide more scrutiny on the
bureaucracy then we would be an issue
network and as i mentioned issue
networks might not be formal they might
not be a formal let's say lobbying group
or interest group
but they can also have influence in the
same way that an interest group does